hi I'm Robert Cogburn lead game designer
at Naughty Dog the uncharted 4
multiplayer beta is out now and runs
until December 13th here's some tips on
mystical xande how to effectively use
them in the uncharted 4 multiplayer data
mystical items are special abilities
that players can purchase from the
in-game store as they're playing these
items can quickly turn the tide of a
match but are not so powerful that
gameplay becomes one sided why don't we
go ahead and take a look at them some
players may recognize this item from
uncharted to the Chintamani stone was
believed to be the key to immortality an
uncharted 4 multiplayer it allows
players to revive allies immediately and
to full health each purchase from the
store gives the player 2 uses marketing
back to the first uncharted game the
wrath of El Dorado allows players to
summon evil spirits that track down
enemy players within a radius around the
sarcophagus this item is excellent for
pushing enemies out of hiding places or
pinning them down by throwing it behind
a large group of players when dealing
with the wrath of El Dorado the best
tactic is to turn around and drop
the staff of our Evancho emits a pulse
that reveals enemies on the radar as the
enemy team you can go out seek the staff
and destroy just know they'll see you
coming indras eternity is a mystical
blade that creates a time work around
wherever it is thrown enemies within the
radius enter a slow-motion stable this
can easily become a death sentence for
those trapped in mr. emotion-filled
boarding an enemy charge or preventing
an enemy tree like the Eldorado finding
the right time to strike with this
mystical is key the spirit of the Djinn
from uncharted 3 imbues the player with
the ability to teleport when activated
instead of rolling or taking cover
players will burst forward in a blaze
allowing rapid travel through the
environment this mystical is great for
closing distance with a shotgun or when
you're trying to leverage melee attacks
while any mystical can turn the tide of
the battle on its own don't be surprised
to find the perfect El Dorado attack
reverse fire well time chintamani later
you'll have plenty of opportunity to
find out for yourself and customize the
perfect load out for your place down
make sure to leave a speed back on the
uncharted 4 multiplayer beta forums jump
online show us what you got
close things